[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the true Jordan YouTube
channel subscribe if you're thirsty for
more today we're talking more underwater
stuff because you lot loved that last
one I tell you I've never had so many
nice comments about myself made us want
to go back diving but then I realized
it's actually quite hard and I'm quite
comfortable sitting here wondering is my
tea hot enough not am I gonna survive
today so the Titanic sub thing is
winding down to a clothes now and uh it
turns out there was one geez I've been
on there 37 times I'm like what is this
dude [__] Epstein's plate surely you
say one Titanic you've seen them all and
I wanted to create a series about these
kind of stories anyway so I'm going to
start a day and we're going to stick
with the c theme that I've started off
with anyway and tell you the
unbelievable story of a man called
Harrison or Kenny now or Kenny was a
kook on a tugboat small boat that was 19
miles off the coast of Nigeria on the
way to an oil Tanga then a huge wave
suddenly capsized the ball sending the
ball under water no this was the first
photo can you because you know he knew
the Seas even as a chef he was not used
to anywhere near this level of problem
before he began rushing through the ship
to try and Escape obviously as you would
the problem was many of the doors were
locked to prevent pirates from entering
which is obviously quite common in those
Waters and we've heard a lot of tales of
pirate attacks and we've all seen the
movie I'm the captain now and he became
trapped inside of one of the officers
toilets as water is pouring into this
ship sinking to the Bottom of the Sea by
some freaky Stroke of Luck an air pump
it was contained within this toilet that
he was stuck in so he could breathe but
he was in total darkness and he was
freezing cold because let me tell you
someone who's been down there he would
have been in agony through how cold he
would have been as the water is rising
up through his body and he is just
barely breathing I found this uh this
good cartoon that actually shows what
happened as the water flowed in it's a
little South Parky but you get the idea
and as other people are escaping you can
see he's holding on inside this toilet
as the board is now on the seabed upside
down so Harrison is a hundred feet
underwater 30 meters that is if he even
figures a way out of that he wouldn't
even make it to the surface without
dying he is [__] his only hope is to
hold on for dear life hope that the
hypothermia doesn't get him the lack of
oxygen doesn't get him anything out of
the the ship doesn't do something and
[__] kill him he needs to be rescued
he needs a hero so as the cartoon shows
he's turning blue he's only in his boxer
shorts as well it's not even like he's
got a cardigan on that he's not I made
it by anything on the plus side you can
piss and [__] anywhere because you're in
a toilet his body is losing heat faster
than his body can create it so slowly
but surely he is dying here he managed
to Fashion himself a platform and this
is where I just love men sometimes
because this is the manliest [__] ever
in it he's stuck on a [__] ball
upside down 30 meters under the water
and here he is thinking on his feet
grabbing everything he can build himself
a platform that he can climb up onto to
get himself out of the water to conserve
his body heat and keep himself Alive
looks like he actually used a bed that
was somehow floating maybe he's got a
quick nap in while he was at it the air
pocket that has been contained inside
this toilet was about 13.5 cubic meters
it takes about 56 hours for carbon
dioxide toxicity to set in when you're
breathing air or Kenny had been down
there for around 60 hours it would have
taken 79 hours from the carbon dioxide
to finally start taking its toll on him
and turn him unconscious contrary to
popular belief when you're trapped in
confined spaces it's not running out of
oxygen that kills you it's actually
re-breathing the carbon dioxide that
will kill you I mean either way you're
[__] so you've got all that time to
contemplate your life to think about
your loved ones having to go on without
you people you're never going to see
again it's basically mental torture as
you're getting colder Panic set in as
you're in this tiny confined space a lot
of people have claustrophobia are in
panic sets in there it's all breathing
and you start having panic attacks this
requires mental strength of the absolute
highest order and from experience I have
seen some really tough guys turn into
Pussycats underwater me included like
when you're panicking underwater and
you're not in control one of the
scariest things people can go through in
life and especially for three days that
is brutal and all the while there's dead
bodies down there with him the people
who you've been working with who you've
probably had good relationships with are
floating around somewhere in this bowl
it must have been like something out of
a horror movie now meanwhile a dive
support vessel has been sent to where
the board sang to recover the bodies so
that at least the relatives of those who
died would be able to bury their loved
ones what they didn't expect was what
they found
on the opposite end of the officer's
mess okay that war and then it goes
around a corner and at this point
they're inside the boat and they've
already recovered four dead bodies what
have you got there that's stairs yeah
okay so you found it so you can hear the
voice of a guy who's speaking very
clearly with a South African accent he
is like the dive supervisor who is up on
the boat talking through the
communication into the diver the reason
the diver's voice is because they're not
breathing uh oxygen it's it's a
combination of gases in order to allow
them to safely stay at that depth for
longer periods of time in the event
where you need to do that leg where
you're having to rescue all of these
people it's not as simple as just jump
down and jump back up this is going to
take a while so as you can see he's been
guided through this ship underwater that
is currently upside down just to
discombobulate them even more and it
isn't you know bright blue water it is
black it is it is hard to figure out
where he's going and when you are having
to use touch and sense to figure out
where you Warren almost developed a 3D
picture of the structure you're inside
in your own mind while battling against
you know agrophobia claustrophobia and
all the Panic that can set in especially
when you're coming up against dead
bodies you're literally having people
floating towards you at times and I
remember once upon a time I signed on
and I said I was gonna you know up for
doing some rescue stuff with the police
and in retrospect I'm glad I never ended
up doing that because this [__] must be
traumatizing for these guys badass
[__]
[Music]
on the shoulder
and there he is amazing absolutely
unbelievable three days underwater so
far beneath the surface no food no water
this is unbelievable and when you look
at the way the dive supervisor reacts
when they first discover him he thought
he was dead he goes oh it's just another
one
yeah it's not as simple as all right
we're just keep them breathing air and
take them up the surface like the sky
has been under pressure at depth for
days on end and you don't know what kind
of scientific approach you're gonna need
to take in order what he's going to
breathe how are you going to get him out
we're going to have to put a diving
helmet on him and dive him out of here
I've never seen anything like this
before this is another level and look at
him what a man
what a man to survive that to stay alive
that's when you find out what your real
survival instincts are because some
people would crumble in that and yet he
is in his boxer shorts just saying I'm
gonna keep going to the better end they
were worried about the severe risk of
decompression related illness or injury
because if you return to the surface too
quickly and I've seen this happen before
where people have not taken enough time
to recover themselves up the surface and
it can cause death it is as serious as
it gets so you know I've seen a man like
like [__] really looking bad before
you know on a diving job I was on where
I thought he was he was absolutely brown
bread and luckily they managed to put
him in a chamber and decompress him
again and he was fine but this is a
Monumental task they now have on their
hands to save them it's not as simple as
we've got to be saved so you'll be
attached like that
first we'll get him dressed and then
we're basically gonna
how's that passage to bring him out is
it okay
it's [__] tight as you can see he's
now drinking water and they are gonna
try and dive him out now if you've never
dived before the best thing to do is do
it in a little scuba gear in a swimming
pool because then if you panic you just
stand up take the help because a lot of
the problem is when people feel the
claustrophobia of the actual equipment
on them they freak out it happens to
most divers when they first start doing
it and this man is gonna have to do it
the first time ever 30 meters earned our
water in Black Water never dived before
in his life to say that's a challenge is
an understatement all right now you
mustn't Panic eh you must listen to me
all right this is like you've never had
a fight before in your first fight is
against Mike Tyson so they put a jacket
on him and they're going to use these
little Clips here to keep a hold of him
are you sure
and they're now having a conversation
with them they can now hear what he's
saying
what's your name
Harrison
okay Harrison my name is Colby
again I'm gonna bring you home okay and
the diver that's helping you know his
name is Nico
okay that's Nico okay there's another
guy on the outside free flow his head so
he doesn't get too hot this dive
supervisor who's talking to him he's
just doing a superb job because he's
keeping him calm for me that's one of
the most like hardest things for anyone
to go through down there is to just stay
calm so he's telling them what's the
name oh this is Nick
whether it's working or not you know I'm
sure he's still worried but it's just
good practice for him what is your rank
okay
front four okay
all right wow so this cable here that
he's holding on ooh that's everything
he's breathing all of his technological
uh needs like the microphone the camera
the light all of that they call it the
umbilical because it's everything you
need basically hold your hands hold two
hands okay all right okay Harrison you
mustn't take your hat off okay
let's just breathe nicely yeah he's
saying you mustn't take your hat off
because a lot of people in a panic just
want to rip it off because everything it
feels so unnatural it's like you're
being strangled almost you know like
it's just that human instinct kicks in
and you're like just get off just get
off and what he's worried about is if
you start with that [__] which happens
when you get out of the ball you are
[__] all right let's go you hold your
umbilical and you listen to me okay all
right we're going now put your head
under water and breathe comfortably okay
foreign
okay how's that are you all right
Harrison are you comfortable this is
Mendel this is absolutely because the
first time you put your head under water
with a hat on it feels completely
bizarre like okay I'm underwater but I'm
breathing and I'm able to talk so that
level of confusion after three days of
nearly dying under like this very
intelligent man who's talking is
obviously saying to him trying to make
it as non-instructional as possible and
follow the diver yeah you must say Roger
okay
all right
now we're bringing you slowly out past
the chief engineer's cabin and coming to
the outside of the vessel okay so
unfortunately the remaining crew members
did not survive but Harrison did thank
God and as it happens you would think
what's the last thing Harrison would
ever want to do again go anywhere in the
other water but this is where Harrison's
different and I really have so much
respect for this guy because as you'll
see in the top comment of this video
Harrison or Kenny abandoned his fear and
became a certified commercial diver in
2015 and the rescue diver who discovered
him at the bottom of the sea was the one
to present him with this diploma I've
heard this a few places so I'm pretty
confident that that is bang on and what
does that say about the mental strength
of this guy that you know he ended up
becoming a career diver after doing his
first dive saving his own life uh with
the help of that great diving team I
mean unbelievable one of the funniest
bits of the story is that he actually
found a bottle of coke when he was down
there and that's what helped him sustain
himself throughout all of this Coca-Cola
I've actually found an interview with
Harrison here I was right in the water
when I have access to nothing right down
inside the water I thought of my family
thought of my my mom my brothers my wife
access to none of them no way to get to
them and I was riding the water and I
know I'm going to die
but the only thing I could put my hope
and trust in and my confidence is called
I don't know it's up to three days
because I was thinking he just said
let's get into the evening I also they
keep on praying praying praying praying
praying when I prayed for some time I
stopped and I said God let that word be
done as it is in heaven because I have
tried my best
and I have called on you and you have
never fade me before and you will never
fit me at all in my life since I said
that
to me if that comes when it comes if
that did not come
I know it's going to rescue me so as I
was there like that
I kept calm and I was bored because I
was not afraid anymore because I know
it's life and death the road the the
line is already drawn powerful words
from Harrison sometimes that's all
people can't hold on it is their
religious beliefs in that moment they
hope and pray that is the difference for
some people between life and death not
necessarily that there is a God or there
isn't a God that's a different video but
the hope and the belief that there is
someone out there who cares and will
save you and send someone the power of
the mind as well I'm a full believer in
that and uh this man is a strong dude
for sure I love this story I hope you
guys enjoyed it I'm going to be doing
different kinds of stories the weird and
wonderful the the miraculous but also
the dark and morbid which I do I find
fascinating I've got to be on a serial
killers really interests me so I'm going
to be doing more of these throughout the
year subscribe if you enjoyed this one
we got plenty more coming as well as the
podcast of course and the fighting
Channel and the pain game and the
football channel the kickoff I'm just
killing it hopefully you enjoyed this
don't forget to subscribe like the video
thank you for watching and I'll see you
on the next one